did you bring your checkbook by the way
i got a huge credit card
like this
i go by two chains two chains i'm over
the top sometimes
wow seriously and right now we're gonna
check out the most expensive this [ __ ]
it's definitely crazy what up what up
should play a partner checking in
to change and today our most expensive
is [ __ ]
we're gonna check out my man elliott
cooper classic cars
hey how are you i'm elliot cucu i'm two
chinese how are you doing
it's two the first thing yeah change
second definitely no middle night you
want to see some nice cars
i definitely want to see some nice cars
what you got to show me well let me show
you around
first of all 280 sc 71 3.5 it was only
made in 1971.
only made in 71. how many did they make
600 only 600 600 cognac interior i like
that
this is the most desirable classic
convertible in the world are you telling
me if i'm driving you if i'm
entertaining you
i'm not pulling my leg i think i want to
buy the car 345
000 or
6 chainz 1960 xk150
jaguar yeah take a look at this
whoa bro no i think this is my favorite
car on this lot bro look at these six
you know
this is only 135 000. i like this one
this definitely i like this one and i
like the price
and there's probably not as many chains
this could easily be a two chain
definitely give you two chains you know
what this is
is it a porsche it's a port what is this
this is 62.
1955. damn that's close
jimmy dean drove a very similar car
unfortunately
he had an accident in this car yeah all
right two chain you've seen a few cars
which do you think is the most expensive
what's your gut feeling this one is
wrapped in some kind of special rope
something comes off the top of this
joint and why would the key go in here
you open this up
and this becomes a wing it comes up here
oh
that's a wing this is the car that cost
more than anything
probably costs two or three of these
damn cars all right so what do you think
it's worth i'm going with 750 000.
oh it's more than 750 oh yeah
i mean the only other price to go is a
million you can't go in there
i can't go over a million i don't want
to even sell a million you can never
even wash the car
the dirt on this car alone is worth 20
pounds
sam you rich ellie what the hell you got
at home
which house one here on the hammond
which one
i don't know ellie tell me hello
two million dollars for this car man i'm
glad to be close to your rich ass
why do you have it looking like rusty
and like dirty this is character man
this is the real deal look at the
interior it's all original there's
something very special
about the life the history of this car
you're getting a work of art
that's history this is one of the most
interesting things in the world
have you ever just got a car like this
and you know probably from my mom's
generation that just had a lot of
[ __ ] pot holes in the seat because i
just remember
smoke holes in my dad's old cadillacs
and stuff like that
that's character though that is but you
can drive in a car
and say see those three holes my dad did
that he was careless
but you're part of his spirit in that
car that's what i'm talking about it's
spirit
i love it i need a picture in front of
this car somebody i need him to get it
from my instagram
and this dude elliott has a lot of
character he doesn't just know about
cars
but he also knows about life and was it
worth it
you tell me leave a comment subscribe to
the gq
channel for more most expensive [ __ ]
double salute
[Music]
you